[Musica]
questa sono io
ai tempi di quando lavorava nel team di
marketing di un'azienda multinazionale
statunitense sui prodotti che sono
prodotti più venduti al mondo lavorare
nel marketing mi ha sempre in 34 mi ha
intrigato
l'idea di lavorare per prodotti che
fossero parte della quotidianità della
gente
per questo sogno e lasciai la mia città
natale bari alla volta di dublino per
approfondire gli insegnamenti di
marketing e finalizzare la mia tesi
dopo la laurea fui molto molto fortunata
a iniziare a lavorare per un colosso del
largo consumo per poi andare a lavorare
nell'azienda leader mondiale di pasta e
prodotti da forno per poi approdare in
una delle multinazionali più ambite da
chi fa marketing questa sono io con mia
sorella stefania e nove anni più piccola
di me e oltre a essere il frutto di un
atto d'amore è stata il risultato della
mia prima vera campagna di marketing
sì avete capito bene quella rivolta ai
miei genitori per convincerli a mettere
al mondo un fratellino o una sorellina
e fu così che nel 1986 nacque stefania è
semplicissima per tornerà la mia storia
nel 2010 andare a trovare stefania
washington al tempo aveva deciso di
entrare nel team come psicoterapeuta in
uno degli ospedali pediatrici più famosi
degli stati uniti in quest'ospedale
stefania osservava l'interazione fra
mamma e bambino all'età
dell'allattamento attraverso uno
specchio multi direzionale quindi
osservava la qualità dell'interazione
alimentare per poi effettuare uno
screening precoce su quelli che erano i
disturbi della nutrizione e
dell'alimentazione e supportava alle
famiglie
a migliorare questa relazione in modo
che fossero fattori protettivi per
l'insorgenza futura di un disturbo
alimentare e di l'opportunità di
guardare di osservare il team al lavoro
e osservai quanto fosse importante la
prevenzione e lo screening precoce su
questi disturbi
questo viaggio mi cambiò la vita torna
in italia e volevo capire quanto i
disturbi della nutrizione e
dell'alimentazione il cui più diffusi
sono anoressia e bulimia fossero diffusi
nel nostro paese e scoprì pensate che
anoressia e bulimia erano la prima causa
di morte per malattia fra i 12 ei 25
anni e che purtroppo solo il 10 per
cento di chi ha bisogno di aiuto riesce
a chiederlo proprio per paura di essere
giudicati e mediamente il tempo che
intercorre fra i primi sintomi e la
richiesta d'aiuto e di tre anni
questi dati mi sconvolsero allora lì
pensai ma quando uno finalmente riesce a
chiedere aiuto cosa trova trova
purtroppo delle strutture non adeguate
purtroppo molte di queste strutture non
sono strutture idonee ad accogliere gli
adolescenti perché sono per lo più
ospedali psichiatrici e solo due
strutture in italia accolgono minori di
14 anni e li senti che rompere il
silenzio attorno a questi disturbi era
cruciale intercettare il disagio verso
cibo peso immagine corporea prima che
diventi disturbo diventava necessario
per iniziare a risolvere il problema in
fondo pensai il marketing e la capacità
di riconoscere e individuare i bisogni
delle persone prima ancora che le
persone ne siano consapevoli e allora
provai a a pensare come potesse
applicare queste competenze in un ambito
completamente diverso cercando di creare
le condizioni per cui i ragazzi e le
loro famiglie potessero chiedere aiuto
se potessero abbattere quella barriera
che impediva del impediva di farlo e da
lì tutti gli anni in cui io avevo
studiato marketing che avevo applicato a
marketing all'interno della mia del mio
percorso acquisirono un nuovo senso la
mia ambizione era diventata quasi
spontaneamente passare da lavorare su
prodotti che fossero parte della
quotidianità a voler sviluppare dei
servizi che potessero migliorarla e
magari cambiarla per sempre
avevo sentivo che era arrivato il
momento per me per andare avanti di
restituire di costituire tutta la
fortuna che avevo avuto ad avere a poter
contare su una famiglia solida che mi
avevano dato sì le radici ma anche le
ali per volare ad aver avuto la fortuna
di iniziare giovanissima a poter
tramutare una mia passione quella per il
marketing in una in una professione che
mi piaceva che mi divertiva e chi mi
darà grandi soddisfazioni ripensai al
concetto espresso da steve jobs durante
il famoso discorso stay hungry stay
foolish
nel 2005 il concetto di connecting box
unire i puntini la capacità di unire i
puntini e quella capacità che ci
permette di connettere idee e concetti
per noi importanti che gli altri in quel
momento non riescono a vedere
ed era proprio quello che volevo fare
volevo unire i punti importanti della
mia vita affetti competenze passione e
relazioni
e così che nel 2014 con stefania
fondammo never give up la onlus che già
nel nome è un invito a non arrendersi ha
nella sua mission quella di abbattere
supportare i ragazzi ad abbattere le
barriere a chiedere aiuto per evitare
che i disagi verso cibo peso e immagine
corporea possano diventare dei veri e
propri disturbi alimentari
stefania direttore scientifico si occupa
di coordinare il comitato scientifico e
la rete di professionisti proprio per
sviluppare programmi di
sensibilizzazione e servizi di supporto
io feci quello che in qualche modo avevo
imparato a fare quindi sviluppare la
campagna di comunicazione gestire le
relazioni con le istituzioni ai partner
e cominciare a fare raccolta fondi per i
primi tre anni e cercare di portare
avanti il mio lavoro parallelamente la
città su never give up ma poi mi accorsi
che nei vecchi vap occupava qua tutto
quasi tutto il mio tempo libero e quindi
decisi dopo vent'anni di marketing di
lasciare il certo per l'incerto e di dei
carmi completamente alla causa
chiaramente la decisione non fu non fu
facile e chiaramente comportò revisione
dello stile di vita in molte rinunce e
anche quando la notizia fu accolta dalle
persone vicino a me fu accolta con
reazioni miste
da una parte mi guardavano con
ammirazione dall'altra si chiedevano
come avessi potuto scegliere di lasciare
il mondo dorato delle multinazionali per
per un progetto nell'ambito sociale che
in italia non ha molto spazio è in
realtà io l'avevo fatto perché pensavo
che lasciando la mia comfort son
succedendo
la vita potesse essere più felice
e per tornare a quello che diceva steve
jobs nel concetto connecting dott
non puoi unire i puntini guardando in
avanti lo puoi fare solo unendoli
guardandoti indietro e quindi l'unica
cosa che ti rimane da fare è quella di
pensare che prima o poi questi puntini
nel futuro suoneranno e così feci furono
anni sono stati anni nonostante
l'impegno e la passione anni complicati
anni di stallo a volte di frustrazione e
a volte vi ripensamento per per il
percorso che avevo deciso di
intraprendere ma anche anni densi di
molti momenti positivi e anche di nuova
energia per esempio come l'ingresso di
ludovica nel comitato centrale oppure
l'interesse crescente dei nostri partner
delle istituzioni a supportare il
progetto assieme ai momenti positivi
arrivarono anche i momenti di grande
grandissima soddisfazione
il primo di questi in marzo del 2018
quando dopo anni di dialogo
la presidenza del consiglio dei ministri
ha scelto la campagna da noi prodotta e
facendola diventare una campagna
istituzionale di governo e trasmettendo
la massicciamente su tutte le reti
questo chiede a noi è un volano per
lanciare la nostra campagna sei mesi
dopo questa campagna ancora in onda
[Musica]
a
[Applauso]
sto bene si sta bene
anoressia e bulimia sono la prima causa
di morte per malattia tra gli
adolescenti loro non ne parlano never
give up può aiutarli il secondo momento
di grande grandissima soddisfazione è
stata l'istituzione della giornata
nazionale per la lotta contro i disturbi
alimentari
dopo un grande lavoro fatto appunto con
le istituzioni per sensibilizzare le
persone su questo tema
questo fu un gancio per coinvolgere i
media affinché mandassero in onda alla
campagna ma non solo dedicassero
all'interno dei programmi degli spazi di
approfondimento proprio per sia per
sensibilizzare chi per indirizzare le
persone che avevano bisogno di noi oggi
never give up è attiva su tutto il
territorio nazionale con programmi di
sensibilizzazione e servizi di supporto
la nostra prossima sfida è quella di
aprire la prima never give up house lane
per keira mouse è un centro che cambia
sostanzialmente il modo di approcciare a
questi disturbi offrendo servizi di
screening precoce marcolin dei ragazzi
sotto i 14 anni e accompagnandoli anche
dopo il trattamento è visto che quella è
una fase delicatissima in cui ad oggi le
ricadute sono altissime
se dovessi guardarmi indietro se dovessi
dire quali sono gli elementi che hanno
fatto sì che oggi sia più felice di
quanto lo fosse in passato
direi sicuramente che mi ha aiutato a
credere nei miei sogni e non aver paura
di lasciare il certo x l'incerto
mi sono fatta sorprendere dal
cambiamento nel momento in cui mi sono
resa conto che le mie ambizioni e le mie
inclinazioni stavano cambiando
ho cercato di mettere a frutto quanto
imparato per inseguire i nuovi sogni
ho cercato linee dei puntini cercando di
non temere il giudizio degli altri e non
l'ho mai mollato grazie